le jour se lève sur la demeure de
françois 1er
c'est l'heure où nathalie prend son
service
nathalie fait partie de l'équipe de
nettoyage du château de chambord je suis
arrivé pour faire une saison on va dire
entre guillemets de dame pipi dans les
toilettes publiques et de fil en
aiguille je suis resté depuis maintenant
assez longue
enfin très longtemps très longtemps
c'était qu'il y à 21 ans au temps où le
château était vide depuis les pièces
sont meublées c'est plus de travail pour
nathalie on rentre davantage de
poussière parce que ça rend davantage de
cailloux c'est plus est plus sale en
plus secondes on est en pleine période
estivale donc c'est normal c'est tout de
suite beaucoup plus de poussière dès
qu'il ya beaucoup de monde
un étage au-dessus walter s'occupe des
parquets
quand il est bien sûr et quand elle est
bien entretenu il reste il reste quoi
bon tous les matins faut le faire mais
sinon il reste ça un parquet qui reste
quand même assez propre 7h30
l'alarmé retentit dans le château
le protocole c'est que tout le monde
descend du château par mesure de
sécurité
vous-même y compris hier désolé c'est
indépendant de volonté pas d' incendies
juste un pigeon ou une chauve souris qui
aura déclenché les systèmes de sécurité
après avoir ciré quelques 300 m² de
parquet ou alter s'attaque aux célèbres
terrasse de chambord puis neige du vent
qui pleuvent en asie je suis ici et faut
faire le boulot
chaque matin ou alter passe près d'une
heure entre ciel et terre à l'endroit
même où la cour de françois 1er
suivait de loin la chasse du roi c'est
un très bon cru c'est en eaux calmes on
travaille au calme c'est après quand les
touristes arrêt c'est pareil quoi mais
là c'est vraiment à c'est vraiment on
travaille dans un grand bonheur à 8h30
l'équipe des caisses et de l'accueil
prend possession des lieux
9 heures les portes s'ouvrent le château
toiletter est prêt à accueillir le
visiteur
dix mille mètres carrés de bâtiments
nettoyer pascal temmar c'est pas une
mince affaire
non ce qui met des bâtiments oui les
bâtiments l'entretien et la restauration
est oui dix mille mètres carrés c'est
énorme mais ça doit être obligatoire à
faire pour une bonne présentation
publique une bonne conservation du
monument alors on l'a dit le domaine est
en pleine transformation
entre autres projets vous venez de
replanter des vignes est-ce qu'elle
existait au temps de françois 1er
alors au tour de france au premier il
existait des vignes puisqu'il ya eu un
inventaire dressé par son fils henry 2 à
sa succession à la succession de
françois 1er et il y avait des fermes
avec les cas reding évidemment c'est
surtout xviiie siècle ce carré de vigne
est apparu sur les plans ou 22,10
arpents pardon ça fait en gros 6
hectares de vignes étaient plantés au
xviiie siècle et donc dans la plus pure
tradition nous avons replanté cette
ligne alors autre nouveauté les gens qui
veulent maintenant être immergé qui
veulent vivre la vie de chambord peuvent
habiter ici parce que vous avez enfin
habiter occasionnellement dans un temps
limité à ce que vous avez ouvert
d'egypte
oui il ya quelques années nous avons
profité de maison
libre dans le village mais parce qu'il y
avait des administrations etc on a relu
qu'alizé tout cela dans le château donc
on a créé deux gîtes dans le village et
un dans une ancienne ferme à l'extérieur
du phare un peu plus loin que le château
en forêt et donc ses gîtes permettent
aux touristes de venir passer quelques
jours agréables une semaine ou un
week-end au pied du château
alors une petite exclusivité où vous
allez refaire les cuisines du château et
on pourra bientôt les visiter oui malka
et non lens étaient les pièces
complètement désaffectée et depuis
quelques années nous avions ce projet et
ça y est nous passons à la phase de
réalisation les travaux vont commencer
en septembre il y en a environ pour 4 5
mois donc il faut patienter mais oman
mars normalement au public en visite
libre on pourra découvrir les cuisines
du xviiie siècle du marquis de polignac
dans le château on va restaurer une
ambiance qui manquait au château ce sera
formidable
donc beaucoup de transformations l'a dit
vous allez refaire aussi la place du
château on sait que ça n'a pas toujours
été facile avec les habitants du village
de chambord est ce qu'aujourd'hui ils
ont toujours des raisons de s'inquiéter
non je crois qu'ils aucune raison de
s'inquiéter maintenant nous améliorons
leur cadre de vie nous améliorons
l'accueil du public et donc tous ces
travaux sont là pour valoriser chambord
et indirectement évidemment les
habitants pascal théberge vous remercie
on se retrouve demain à demain corinne
du cinéma présent avec la nouvelle
aventures d'alex guéri le jeune
réalisateur tourangeau vient de débuter
le tournage d'un nouveau film sur ses
terres et cette fois il s'agit d'un long
métrage rencontre signée aurélie albert
et patrick ferré ce projet de long
métrage c'est avant tout une aventure
humaine un rêve de gosse
parce que lorsque j'avais 10 ans j'ai
découvert le film jurassic park de
steven spielberg et ce jour là j'ai j'ai
compris qu'en fait ce qui m'intéresse
c'est finalement plus que tous étaient
de de raconter à mon tour des histoires
et faire rêver les gens le temps d'un
film
fini le rêve de gosse alex est
aujourd'hui un cinéaste accompli quatre
années de réflexion et 7 versions de
scénario plus tard le tournage commence
action en réalité j'avais un peu
abandonné
il y ait une espoir on va dire de
pouvoir faire ce premier long métrage on
met 30 ou 35 ans parce que c'est un peu
près 10 de la moyenne d'âge d'un jeune
réalisateur français pour un premier
long et
et en fait en janvier dernier avec
l'équipe des loups blancs qui donc avec
qui j'ai évolué au quotidien m'ont dit
que c'était aussi voile alors leurs
objectifs de vie que c'était c'était
quelque chose qu'il fallait pas lâcher
et donc du coup
on s'est penché sur le projet et ont
ainsi mis à fond donc là on est neuf
mois plus tard et c'est le début du
tournage après avoir réalisé une
centaine de courts métrages et remporter
une trentaine de prix dont quelques-uns
à hollywood
alex passe aux choses sérieuses mais
toujours avec le sourire
c'est l'histoire d'une relation entre
une mère et sa fille y est et
malheureusement je pas pouvoir en dire
trop parce que c'est un thriller
psychologique qui invite le spectateur
en fait à résoudre une énigme tourangeau
de naissance et de coeur il a voulu
réaliser ce long métrage dans sa région
mais il n'est pas seul dans cette
aventure
une dizaine de personnes l'accompagnent
le fait qu' un jeune ça veut pas dire
qu'il n'a pas d'expérience déjà parce
que alex il a quand même un cv assez
remplie et puis c'est sa passion qui
compte c'est pas non c'est une question
d'âge la pression est forte et le timing
serré
l'objectif est de terminer le tournage
d'ici quelques semaines pour une sortie
dès le début de l'année 2016 c'est la
fin de la partie régionale du 19 20 mais
restez avec nous on se retrouve juste
après la météo pour l'édition des
locales du centre a tout de suite
demain matin le soleil maîtrise
complètement le ciel aucun nuage n'osera
s'y aventurer paradoxalement son
omniprésence n'aura pas d'effets
bénéfiques dans un premier temps sur les
minimales qui débuteront vers 12 ou 13
degrés voire 14 en touraine cela dit ça
va chauffer assez vite et la fin de
matinée sera déjà bien douillette pas
d'invité surprise l'après-midi le bleu
reste pure et exempt de toute intrusion
nuageuse du coup les températures vont
continuer de s'envoler l'après midi pour
atteindre 31 ou 32 degrés ces six ou
sept plus qu'aujourd'hui
voyant la tendance jusqu'au début de
week-end jeudi matin quelques passages
nuageux donne de rares averses mais dans
l'après midi le soleil se montre à
nouveau royal les minimales sont
nettement plus douce vendredi rebelote
pour quelques ondées en journée avec un
tout petit risque d'orage le thermomètre
retrouve les mêmes valeurs qu
aujourd'hui à savoir 25 degrés maxi
samedi l indice de confiance est assez
faible mais météo france tend vers une
amélioration